comment est-ce qu'on peut penser à
intégrer des pays en conflit alors je
pense que le grand défi pour l'Union
européenne sera l'article
47 qui est une garantie de sécurité à
chaque membre de l'Union européenne la
France est le seul pays qui a évoqué cet
article après les attaques du Bataclan
c'est une clause de solidarité au sein
de l'Union européenne alors si on
s'imagine qu'on intègre un pays tel que
l'Ukraine qui restera peut-être sous une
pression forte de de la part de la
Russie il faudra avoir un cadre de
garantie sécuritaire qui va au-delà de
l'Union européenne parce qu'elle n'est
pas équipée pour cela c'est pour cela
que je pense et ça c'est pas dans notre
rapport parce que ça va au-delà du
mandat mais est important pour répondre
à la question on ne peut pas séparer la
question de l'adhésion à l'oton ou bien
un cadre de garantie sécuritaire si
c'est pas euh l'adhésion à l'OTAN mais
quand même un cadre de garantie
sécuritaire de sécurité et de défense
pour les pays qui vont intégrer l'Union
européenne si la Russie reste la menace
qu'elle est aujourd'hui parce que
l'Union européenne n'a pas les moyens de
garantir la sécurité et la défense de
ses États-membres et on a l'article de
solidarité qui les oblige et donc là il
y a une nouvelle situation géopolitique
dont on doit tenir compte